joining us now is Nick Thomas Simmons
Shadow International Trade secretary but
of course she were previously Shadow
Home Secretary I think I'm right in
saying we heard there from the business
secretary who was also Home Secretary
until a couple of weeks ago
um that the government was in danger of
breaking the law were you surprised by
that
I wasn't surprised to hear that
particularly given what's happened with
Sue Ella Braverman who has also of
course been using private email to send
sensitive information but was
nonetheless appointed to Cabinet as a
result of a grubby deal to get Rishi
sunak into the leadership of the
conservative party putting party before
country this issue at Manson is an
extraordinarily serious one and the
government has completely failed to get
a grip of the issue of tens of thousands
of people risking their lives in small
boats crossing the channel
do you think there could have been a
scenario where the previous Home
Secretary was given legal advice one day
and that advice had been different with
sir Brotherman the day before it's
difficult to believe that that is the
case uh Grant chaps has been very clear
in terms of what he was advised and it's
difficult to see how that would have
changed very quickly this yet again
calls into question Rishi sunax judgment
both in reappointing Sue Ella bravaman
in the first place given her previous
conduct but also now keeping her in
position when you've got other members
another member of the cabinet out on the
media this morning indicating problems
with her judgment what would you expect
your leader to do if one of his cabinets
Shadow cabinet had written the sort of
messages that Gavin Williamson wrote to
the former Chief whip a woman I would
expect Kirsten to act as he always has
done in matters of this kind very
decisively and I wouldn't expect that
position to be that position that person
to be continuing uh position yes and the
point the issue here is that it is
shocking frankly that when there was a
complaint that Rishi sunak then goes
ahead and makes the appointment of Gavin
Williamson to his cabinet it's another
good we've had the Home Secretary that
I've referred to this is another of
these grubby little deals to get Rishi
sunak the leadership of the conservative
party once again putting party interest
before country with Kia stama you would
get country first party second but can
we not acknowledge that it was a Heat of
the Moment message that he sent he
wanted to pay his respects to her
majesty he wanted to be at the funeral I
mean in hindsight we've all written
stuff we shouldn't have but it was on
two separate occasions wasn't it it
wasn't just one occasion there was the
issue around the invitations the funeral
there's a there's a late uh exchange
regarding uh I understand it was the a
vote on a particular evening so it isn't
just a a one-off occasion where there
was this very unprofessional loss of
temper and we must go back to what Rishi
sunak promised on the steps of Downing
Street the the high standard of Ethics
the professionalism yet he hasn't even
appointed an independent advisor on
ethics despite promising to do so yeah
this is trying to sort out the economy
and he's also had to go to charmel
Sheikh to because Boris Johnson's there
otherwise well premises are capable of
multitasking and this is an
extraordinarily important thing
particularly after the pre the previous
prime minister but one in particular
Boris Johnson who trashed standards in
public life it was Rishi sunak himself
who said that restoring trust was a
priority but he just isn't backing up
the those words with action I'm afraid
we also spoke to business secretary
about what was going to happen in the
Autumn statement he didn't give too much
oil that I sort of got the impression
that there will be an extended windfall
tax that could include fossil fuels
label would support that
we've argued for an extension to the
windfall tax we've argued for the
principle of a windfall tax since the
very start of the year because there are
companies who are making these excess
profits uh out there tens of billions of
pounds that the government shouldn't be
dragging its feet on and should frankly
already have put in place measures the
problem that we have is we have a crisis
now that was made in Downing Street and
working people are paying the price the
very reason we're having this debate
about the extent of the economic pain
people are going to face is because of
the failure of this conservative
government should we be paying
reparation money to people like China
uh well I'm not aware that China is
asking for uh reparations and the terms
of course loss and damage uh in terms of
loss and damage the government has uh
been pushing for this to be on the
agenda at cop 27 we would also put it on
the agenda at cop27 but it isn't just
about the payment of loss and damage in
terms of money going one way there is a
self-interest as well a powerful
self-interest in doing this but if China
asks for money should we give it to them
I I the China is not asking for money I
think the debate here is about countries
like for example Pakistan where there's
been 30 percent of the country that's
been underwater or island nations like
the Maldives that are particularly
vulnerable to climate change but it is
also in our self-interest because having
countries around the world that are
themselves energy secure means that the
whole world energy Market is not as
vulnerable to shocks like Putin's legal
invasion of Ukraine it's important in
terms of the refugee crisis in terms of
preventing people from becoming refugees
but it's also important from if I could
just say this as from a trade point of
view because we need to be leading on
this agenda for our reputation around
the world and our reputation in
international Aid and the international
Aid budget where the the money would
come from is important in gaining
trading opportunities as well how much
of Matt Hancock's reported 400
000 pound fee for being on I'm a
celebrity should he donate do you think
to the dyslexic Children's Charities
that he says he's representing when he
goes in there well if his purpose of
going on there is to promote dislaction
he has done campaigning on that in the
past then of course you you would expect
him to want to come out and and indicate
what that proportion was and you'd
expect it to be very significant but the
the issue here is that mohancock is a
serving Member of Parliament now if
people want to go on I'm celebrity get
me out of here that's absolutely fine
but trying to be a member of parliament
at the same time as the issue how on
Earth can matter Hancock say that he he
is serving his constituents when he's
away for what could be a significant
amount of time doing this Ali's got his
phone in his laptop with him which I'm
surprised about because of course none
of the other contestants students can do
that but you know you can work remotely
can't you well I can't say I'm a
religious Watcher of I'm a celebrity but
I've seen I've quite right okay I've
seen it but I've seen it a number of
times in the past I've not come across
contestants actually working remotely uh
in the jungle before and I think my
Hancock's constituents would rightly
question why it is that at any point but
particularly this point with the cost of
living crisis that we have that his
priorities are elsewhere come on I know
you're going to vote for him to eat
something horrible unmentionable aren't
you you are aren't you the the well I
may be tempted okay but I have to say
having having seen my Hancock across
this batch box many times the only thing
I'd like to see him eat is his words
frankly ah very good I see where you're
going with that it's good to talk to you
thank you very much for joining us thank
you